viii is head of ism's journalism
journalism is a product to modern
history and it's shaped by the politics
of the places where it works and if the
democracies it's based on the ideals
that knowledge is important that
expression should be free and that
reliable information is good for society
has been driven by the invention of new
technologies such as paper printing
electricity photography and now of
course digital social media the internet
it's changed radically over time from
medieval scribes recording more and
taxes to paid pamphleteers and coffee
shops waging political battles to
mass-market newspapers that use new tech
like trains and telephones to gather and
spread the news to television and radio
that allows us to see hear and connect
with the rest of the world
the BBC's rich Dimbleby z' radio reports
from Belsen concentration camp brought
the horrors of the Holocaust of the
world television journalists like dan
Rather and photographers such as Don
McCullen showed America the brutal
reality of Vietnam and reporters from
the Washington Post Metro desk forced a
presidential resignation over Watergate
a journalism became more influential so
politicians battled to control it
journalism was always about power power
of information holding power to account
or providing propaganda it claimed to
make and break three ears swing
elections and even star wars it's
produced heroes who have revealed
scandals such as systematic child abuse
by pedophile priests it's also created
monsters who ruined lives and broke the
law such as the journalists who hacked
into people's phones now it's all
changing again automatic software
programs are writing bot journalism
citizens broadcast on their phones
algorithms created by huge technology
companies shape the flow of news as
people like or retweet the facts and
opinions they want to share that's meant
an explosion of content at either way of
information much of it Falls furious and
fractures people are confused about what
to trust uncertain what is true
fearfully the anger conflict and bias
they find online we're in an age when
populist leaders and shadowy interest
groups use the cliche fake news to
attack journalists and deliberately
mislead the public so why did journalism
failed to see all this coming do we even
need your miss anymore fake news is
actually good news the trustworthy
reliable journalism it's a chance for
the news media to show why they're
needed to sort out the truth from lies
and speak for the citizen the digital
age is a chance for journalism to
reinvent itself with new tools such as
virtual reality or artificial
intelligence the Internet provides
massive competition for the mainstream
media but it also offers pathways to new
business models such as membership
subscription and collaboration most of
all it offers an opportunity for
journalism to get back in touch to be
more diverse relevant and engaging in a
social world where emotional and values
drive our communications journalism
needs to rediscover the human touch and
also to get back some key traditional
ideals to be reliable responsible and to
tell the stories that help to explain
our complicated and often frightening
world
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon